Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to get really candid tonight because
this is the official Q&A. We've never
done a Q&A with you guys before. Um we
have been off the radar a little bit. I
think our last live was maybe eight days
ago or something. But it doesn't mean
we're out of content. That doesn't mean
we don't we're not about to come out
with some stuff. We have just had a lot
going on
>> and so we want to be able to talk to you
guys about it. We want to hear from you
guys. We want to know what you guys want
to hear about what you guys have been
hearing. I saw somebody mentioning
right here
about uh I've heard that the sun is
doing strange things. I have heard that
too. I actually just talked to somebody
on the phone that said he was gonna send
me a link. He might even be in here
tonight. My good friend Britain.
Um I've been seeing some weird stuff. Uh
two sons, three sons.
>> Have you seen these?
>> So you know what the Mastercard logo
looks like?
>> Mhm.
>> So they say that this Mastercard logo is
actually happening right now. I'll pull
it up. Let's see. Uh, master car.
>> Um, make sure I hit the right
button here. I don't even know if I got
this this thing. Yeah. So, the
Mastercard logo. Who's on screen right
now? Neither one of us.
>> I go full screen or something. Let's
see.
>> Okay.
>> So, the Mastercard logo
is like a predictive programming thing.
something that's going on with the sun
right now. And uh is anybody else?
So you guys go ahead and start send
sending in some questions. We got 20
people in here right now currently.
>> We got one.
>> I'm not expecting a lot of interaction
tonight. These Q&A things, man, I I'll
just be honest. When YouTubers that I
watch do Q&A day, I don't watch. and I
don't even watch cuz I'm just like uh to
me I feel like Q&A is like you don't
have anything to talk about and so we're
just going to do Q&A today. That's
really not the way it is tonight. I
actually got so much to talk about that
I can't even
>> behind on recording.
>> This is u I knew I knew that was going
to happen. How can I mute this thing?
>> I don't know.
>> Maybe it calmed out. Oh,
I wish I could just turn off Messenger,
but
I have something pulled up to show you
guys. I could go ahead and just show
that and knock it out. Get out of here.
So, Oh, yeah. So, we didn't talk about
the Mastercard thing. So, yeah. So,
there are apparently two suns in the
sky. Let's Let's look this up real
quick. Two suns red. I don't know.
Something about it being red, right? So,
I keep seeing this going on right now.
Pictures of this happening.
>> Oh,
>> yeah. People are
>> When did this happen?
>> Uh, this has been going on. Look, this
is the daily jargon. It looks like that
logo looks um Well, here we go. Two Suns
on
>> NBC.
You can always You can always trust the
news mainstream media.
>> Daily Mail.
When was this? Um,
oh, this is March 2011. I was going to
say I've heard of this type of thing
before
>> because I've been down the rabbit hole
since about 2011
was when I started really looking into
this like conspiracy type stuff.
But this is more recent right here. This
uh I keep seeing this picture, this red
sun. When was this?
Um 2025.
June June 3rd 2025.
I don't know. I mean, it's really weird
looking, but yeah, you know, I don't
know. I have heard that
China made a fake sun. China fake sun.
Have you guys heard this? So, China is
not creating a literal fake sun, but
rather they are developing a nuclear
fusion reactor called the experimental
advanced superconducting
takam
tak
>> which is nicknamed the artificial sun.
Um, this device aims to replicate the
process of nuclear fusion that powers
stars, potentially offering a clean and
virtually limitless energy source. The
East Reactor recently achieved a new
record by maintaining plasma at
extremely high temperatures for over a
thousand seconds. I don't know. That's
that's one idea that came to my mind
when I heard about this two sons thing
going on.
Um what's going on in the chat?
Um as long as you say love you guys. Oh,
we love you. Thank you so much.
>> We thank you guys so much for being here
for
real talk like we cannot do this without
you guys. And that's something that we
can get super candid about too.
Um,
just to let you guys know that this is
our full-time job. Like we we stepped
away from a steady paycheck a year ago
now. Came to truth is a year old as of
this month, July. The first live video
we did was I I talked about um how there
was going to be an AI prison sentence.
The scientists were coming up with this
new
way where AI would go into your brain
and you could serve years worth of a
sentence in seconds or minutes.
>> It would it would be minutes in real
time, but in your brain you spent years
going through prison rehabilitation, all
this stuff. And you know, like when you
have a dream, you go to sleep and you
you doze off for like literally seconds
and you're like, "Whoa, I just had this
crazy dream. I was doing all this." And
somebody's like, "Dude, you like barely
fell asleep."
>> Your brain is so powerful. Like time
just ceases to exist in your mind. And
we talked about some of the implications
of that. Like what would it be like?
Say you were assaulted by somebody,
sexually assaulted,
and the next day you see them walking
the streets
>> and they're like, "No, I did my time. I
did years of time in my brain, you
know."
>> Yeah. And part of why people go and have
a sentence anyway is to have them be
kept out of the real world so you as the
victim and your family can actually have
time to heal and live life without them
being a a danger to society. So, that
was never going to be a good plan.
>> Yeah, that's some like they make movies
about that stuff like Born Identity and
stuff like that.
>> Um, Liv, man, I don't know why that's so
small. I wish I could make that bigger.
But Liv said, "Just logged in from
Australia. Love your work. Uh, you too.
How's the book going? Are you doing any
more children's books?" Good question.
Mhm.
>> So,
the first time we did the fundraiser for
this book, I went live for like maybe
two hours and we raised enough money to
print 2,000 copies of the book.
>> Mhm.
>> I was only shooting for a thousand and
that was amazing. Uh, printed those
books in January or the end of December.
I know it was New Year's time.
And, um, in six months they were all
gone.
Now, I I um took a leap of faith and put
it on the credit card. This is why we're
getting super candid with you guys. We
need your support. I thought, well, man,
surely this is going to get funded. You
know, people are just going to jump on
it because now even more people know
about it. Now, this Alio movie came out.
Disney's really pushing this whole
aliens are your friends and just go out
into a field and lay on a sigil and pray
for aliens to come abduct you and they
will. And now we really more than ever
need ammunition against that message. As
Christians, we need the truth against
that message. And so I was like, no
questions asked. you know, I'm gonna
step out in faith, put on the credit
card. It's $5,000 to print
uh 2,000 books, which is a great deal
because the books are like $3 each or
something. And I want it to be a free
resource. I don't want anyone to have to
pay for this. God has provided the first
run. People are ordering books by the 50
and hundreds.
And so, I did that last month and now
I'm down to like 300 books. So they're
they got ordered way faster than the
first time.
>> Yet only half was paid for by donors. So
that that kind of is stressful for us
because
>> we we depend on donations to keep this
thing going, to keep our lives going, to
keep the ministry going. And um I just
was really hoping that that would have
got paid for. So, we're actually $2,400
in debt to that. But, man, they they
flew quick. I actually turned it off.
You guys never get to see little Chloe.
Oh, this is our baby. Look how sweet she
is. Oh, she's shy. Um,
so they're going super super fast. only
got 300 books left out of 2,000. And I
turned them off on the website because
it was becoming a full-time job. That's
another that's another thing. Shipping
books is not
>> Oh, it's a pain.
>> Easy. I mean, you're I'm weighing how
many books they want. 25. I got to put
them on a scale and I have to go, you
know, a little line by line their name
and checking make copy and paste the
name, the address. You know, sometimes
the USPS.com doesn't like the address
and I got to email them, oh, what do you
have a different address? and weighing
it up and measuring the packages and
taping them up. And I spend literally
the whole day race to the post office
with a ton of packages, ship them off,
and I'm like, "Well, uh, that was all I
could do today. I couldn't do any
research. I couldn't work on a video. I
spent the whole day shipping out books,
and I got more to do tomorrow." Mhm.
>> So, one reason I had to take them down
or turn them off on the website is
because it just got to be way way too
full-time job. And I only got 300 left
and I want to take these to the
conventions.
It is a free book. People that order it
online, they're having to pay shipping,
but they're paying like $15 for 50 books
even. And so, they're like pennies. But
if I ever see anyone in person, I'm
like, "You want a book? You want 10
books? You want 20? Hey, how many can
you give away? So, I just got back from
the GC,
>> which is an Adventist convention thing.
A bunch of a bunch of ministries are out
there, and I I got to see a whole bunch
of people out there. I got to give away
a bunch of free books there. Little
Light Booth was there. They they carried
some of the books to give away for free.
Button to Christ, an amazing ministry
that does deliverance ministries, prayer
warriors, they were giving away the
books. I mean, they see stuff. They they
deal with like things in the house are
flying around and stuff. So, they they
know all about spiritual warfare and all
that. So,
>> so just to answer the full question, are
there any more children's books?
>> Yes.
>> Yes, there are.
>> There's another children's book in the
works. My 14-year-old daughter is an
amazing artist. Ah, I wish I could. Man,
that would have been perfect tonight to
have some of her drawings to show you
guys. But
she has two characters that she came up
with a while back called Gooey and
Shadow. Gooey is a orange goofy cat. And
Shadow is like this black cat that's
more serious. And they're kind of like
the odd couple, like best friends, but
one's sillier, one's more serious. And
the book is basically the Prodal Friend.
That's a working title. I don't plan on
calling it the prodical friend, but
that's the story. And basically, they're
best friends and Shadow starts getting
into some other stuff, like, "Hey man,
why don't we play this game?" And it's
like a violent video game. And Gooy's
like, "Oh man, we shouldn't be playing
that." Like, "Oh man, you're no fun" or
whatever. And they start kind of
separating and Guy's like all alone.
Like, man, he's like, you know, playing
with the ball by himself and he misses
his friend. He starts praying for his
friend. his friend is actually getting
into like
>> Pokemon cards. They got, you know, evil
symbols on them and eventually gets to
like tarot cards, Ouija boards, bad
music, bad movies,
and violent video games and stuff. And
Gooey is praying for his friend every
night. And Shadow starts to experience
some stuff like shadowy figures in the
night start to freak him out and stuff
and he cries out to Jesus. Repents,
burn. It doesn't burn. We decided not to
burn in the kids book, but he throws
away all his stuff in the trash. And
they come back together, best friends
again. And Shadow, you know, is
apologized. I should have never got into
all that stuff, man. That stuff was
freaky and all this. And so teaching
your kids
what kind of things to stay away from,
how you can pray for your friend if they
start going off the rails, start going
astray, and how prayer works and how God
can get their attention and bring them
back and save them out of that pit. So
awesome question, live out the chaos.
>> Um,
I hear Okay, that's what this I don't I
haven't read yet. I hear way too much
about pre-trip rapture. Please tell
people there's no pre-trip. We have a
video. So, I I got it pulled up here.
Let's see.
Um, we have a video on the rapture
and rockets right. There is no such
thing as a pre-tribulation rapture in
the Bible. I can't even believe that
Christians today still believe this.
This was the first doctrine that I
studied on my own and was like, "This is
not even real." I mean, just studying
out the Bible proved to me that this was
not a real doctrine. So, right here, you
have it's 11 months ago under our live
tab, but it says John Rich says
preerttrib rapture is false doctrine on
Tucker Carlson show. I give every verse,
every verse that could possibly be used
for the pre-trip rapture, for the second
coming, whatever. And um yeah, there's
just no such thing. It's it's not in
there. Um the truth about the rapture is
that it is the second coming. They are
not two separate events. It says that,
you know, people always say, "We're
changing a moment, twinkle of an eye."
But what's the verse say? At the last
trump, at the last trumpet.
If you read Revelation, you're going to
find out there are seven trumpets, each
being sounded at the sound of a plague
being poured upon the earth.
>> Therefore, the last trumpet would be
after the last plague. It's the last.
We're going to be here for the plagues,
guys.
>> Just like the Egypt, just like the
Israelites were still in Egypt for 10
plagues, we're going to be here for the
seven plagues, but we will not be
affected
if we are sealed. You know, people, I've
heard this stuff all the time. God
doesn't beat his wife and all this
stuff. He's not a wife beater, meaning
that he wouldn't leave his bride in the
earth and pour down a bunch of plagues
on him. Well, he did in Egypt. Just go
back and read the Moses story. The
Egyptians were not raptured out of
Egypt. They weren't even taken out of
the city when the plagues were poured
down,
>> but they were not affected by them. And
um man, there's some when you watch that
video, you're going to see nail in the
coffin proof. Job even says the oldest
book of the Bible, Job, older than
Genesis. Um it it predates Genesis when
it was written, not in the time, not in
the story. Of course, Genesis talks
about the creation, but
Job says
that um
that he will rise, meaning,
this is another topic, too. When you're
dead, you're dead until the resurrection
of judgment day.
>> But Job says that clearly says, "If man
dies, will he live again? All the days
of my appointed time, I will wait until
my change comes." Now, what is that
change? That change is exactly what
Paul's talking about when he says,
>> "I'm changed in the moment, twinkle of
an eye." And then it goes on and it
says, "After your wrath is passed," what
is God's wrath? God's wrath is the
plagues poured upon the earth. So, Job,
the book of Job is saying that our
change comes, our resurrection into new
life, put on immortality, all that
happens after God's wrath is passed.
Meaning if you're alive, you're gonna be
here for that wrath and then you're
gonna be changed though.
>> So, good questions here. Also, to let
you guys know, Aubrey and I are getting
over a sickness.
>> I don't know if we had the COVID or
something for
>> it was like a week.
>> A week longer
>> and then I had it a week and a half.
>> Longer than a week. Man, I never get
sick. When I do, it's gone in two or
three days. This was
>> This was bad for both of us.
>> Yeah. So, that's another reason why we
haven't really had much going on. And I
thought tonight we're going to have a
hard time. We're going to be coughing
like crazy. But honey and cough drops
and tea
>> has been very helpful.
>> Yep.
>> Um Shannon says, "Happy anniversary,
Candid Truth." Thank you for that. Hope
you are blessed. Um Judith says, "Hope
you are blessed from HT, Texas. Keep
grinding for Jesus." Houston, we want to
come see you. I want to come to Texas,
man. I've I've been to Texas
twice, three times, something like that.
I've only spoke in Texas once. I want to
come
>> I'm trying to speak at X Ministries
Church.
>> I talked to Craig Lewis for 30 minutes
on the phone one time. He wanted me to
come out there and talk about the anime
stuff and then now I just can't get in
touch with him anymore. I've I've texted
him a couple times here and there and he
would, you know, when he puts out a
really good video, I say, "Dude, that
video is awesome." And he'll say,
"Thanks, man." or whatever, but we
haven't really spoke on any kind of
like, "Let's let's schedule a time for
you to come out and talk." He said,
"Man, my congregation, I see it every
day, every church, you know, every week
I see people in my church audience
wearing Naruto and wearing these shirts,
these anime things." He said, "I knew
that stuff was messed up." and he
watched our he watched Little Light's
documentary on anime and he he wanted me
to come out there and share it. But if
you're watching Craig Lewis, invite us
out. I want to speak on on that.
Late to the show. Somebody said late to
the show. What's been said, guys?
>> I haven't missed much yet. Uh, speaking
of two suns, I came across a video on
YouTube last night about it being 160
degrees Fahrenheit in China.
Whoa. 160 degrees.
>> Wow.
>> What?
>> I don't know if Fahrenheit I don't know
the difference in Fahrenheit and
whatever. Like, but that sounds hot. 160
degrees.
>> Um,
would love to donate if you use PayPal.
you're in luck. You're blessed because
we do use PayPal. Um, if you go to our
website, candidtruth.org,
candidtruth.org,
there's a little tab up here that says
donate. You can click the donate button.
Don't ask why a car shows up. It just
does
>> every time.
>> It's it's like in the template. Um,
maybe it's subliminally asking saying
that we need a car. Um, PayPal right
here. PayPal is executebrandgmail.com.
That's our PayPal. We got Cash App,
Vinmo, Zel, PayPal,
and you can wire money to us.
Um, yeah, we would
be ever eternally grateful for that. Um,
for your support. We can't do this
without you guys. Like, real talk. like
we cannot do this without you. We don't
have jobs.
I actually picked up a job in GC at the
GC conference I was talking about just
to pick up some loose ends, you know,
but really we don't have time to pick up
jobs. I thought when we did this
ministry like, hey, you know, on the
side I could do some graphic work and we
don't have time, man. And I
don't think people realize how little
you really make being Let's just be
honest also. We're not monetized at all.
>> And so when you are monetized on
YouTube,
>> um I don't know, should we like burst
that bubble?
>> Yeah.
>> Even ministries that are bigger like
Little Light, they only make maybe 2,000
on YouTube
>> a month.
>> A month.
>> On a good on a good month. 2 month.
>> On a good month. And so you actually
don't make that much money on YouTube
being a YouTuber if you get monetized.
>> So that is really all we do is for you
guys here on YouTube, putting movie uh
videos out and speaking
um and donations is really how we make
ends meet and what we how we live and
continue to put content out for you
guys. So,
>> this is a good question from Deborah
Weber. Question, why do you think
churches are so close-minded when it
comes to stuff like this? That is a
great question. I wish I knew the
answer, but I think the answer just
literally is closed-mindedness.
People are comfortable with the truth
that they have. They're comfortable with
their life.
this type of stuff that we're talking
about is like earth shaking.
>> Yeah. Um so we've always had an interest
in these topics. Obviously that's why
we're here. But I'll just tell you, when
you're someone who um has been that way
and you go to a party or you go to your
friend's house and um you don't
necessarily love I guess all kinds of
parties, but you bring up topics like
like we're talking about like, "Oh man,
did you know that there's chemtrails and
they're controlling the weather?" People
really look at you weird. So, we know
that's just a weird com like fact about
us that we were those people. Um, I've
learned now to stop being that way a
little more. You only do it on a
platform where you're meant to do that.
But I just know that this has been us
and this is where we do it. And I think
you're right very much so, Mikey, as
well because
people don't want to talk about
uncomfortable topics. They want to be in
a safe, pretty, happy rose uh colored
glasses type of world even as as faulted
um as it is and crazy and they just
don't want to hear it. So,
>> yep. You know, the Bible talks about in
the last days people are going to be
eating and drinking and marrying and
giving a marriage and it's just talking
about people are going to be living life
as normal. All the signs are here. Like
I mean it's crazy like from the esoteric
world to the political realm to what's
happening in the church. Every sign and
even in the um just natural disasters,
quote unquote natural disasters, all of
that stuff is literally signs of the
times. I know Jesus coming back not even
in double digits. Like I don't even
think we got 10 years. Well, and I want
to give some people hope because we've
had questions. People say, "What do I do
with my family members who don't
believe?" Guess what? We're in the same
boat.
>> We have whole sides of the family, if
not most all of our family, who don't
believe these things, one topic or
another, and they're very hard to share
with. They don't want to hear it either.
It's too scary for them. Most of them
will shut you down quickly. And so, you
really cannot share with someone who
doesn't want to hear it. And that's what
we've learned. You just have to kind of
be nice. Be
there for them in the normal ways you
can. Don't go out overextending
yourself. Especially if, let's just be
honest as well. Some of us have family
members that aren't safe. And if you
were to try to pursue them and make them
your project, you might end up having
them take advantage of your resources,
maybe your life, all kinds of things.
>> So, you just do what you can. be nice
and if they want to ever know truth or
if a moment does come up, you really
wait for the right moment. Even if it
was like you could spring it on them in
a a little moment and just kind of fire
away, that's not the right moment.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you really have to know with the
Holy Spirit's help when that is.
>> That's what I've learned to do, too.
Like when God first woke me up, opened
my eyes, I was for eight and a half
years, I was a Christian with no fruit,
doing all the wrong things that I
shouldn't have been doing,
and I just thought, you know, I got
freedom in Christ or whatever. I do
whatever I want to.
>> And uh God woke me up in an instant.
December 2011 stood me out of my seat.
All of a sudden, symbols of every major
corporate logo is like the satanic
symbol and everything made sense. and
new world order, FEMA camps, chemtrails,
everything instantly.
And um I started blasting it, man. Like
on Facebook, I was just I worked
outside. I was a valet parker and I was
taking pictures of the sky all day long.
And I have pictures on my Facebook from
that still blow my mind. I'm like, I
can't even believe that is that was like
they were spraying so hard. Harp ripples
like all the way across the sky. Like
the pictures I took were mind-blowing in
your face. You can't deny that this is
geoengineering
and I would post it every day and my
friends list was dwindling and people
were telling me I was crazy and uh
that's over the years God has refined me
and given me more tact
>> about how to how to share certain things
but mainly it's waiting for people to
open up to you. you know, you can share
little nuggets of truth here and there
on your Facebook or something, but
um I I see a lot of people that don't
have tact. You know, I can
>> I can make a post about something
and suddenly there's somebody in there
saying
the earth is flat and motionless and his
name is Yahweh and uh you got to keep
the Sabbath and and it's just like whoa.
Yeah, those things are true, but
I don't know how it pertains to the
post. I don't know like who this is
meant for. Is it meant for me? Is it
meant for someone else? And that's how I
respond to people like that. I'm like,
you know, you gota you have to use tact
when you share truth or you're going to
really put up a wall and turn people off
and you look nuts.
>> So, good question. live out the of the
chaos
says, "Mikey, I've noticed a huge health
transformation since your early Little
Light Studios days. Will you be doing
health presentations? Aubrey always
glows with good health." And Rocket
said, "Aubrey always glows." It's true.
She looks beautiful all the time. I tell
her,
>> "Thank you.
>> She looks young. She looks amazing. She
doesn't always feel like she does, but
she does. Everybody tells her all the
time." So, she does do health talks and
um
she actually has a presentation that
she's gonna do here because it's kind of
in the vein of conspiracy or whatever. U
talking about xenoestrogens, plastics
and everything, changing your hormones
like
>> from everything your carpets, your
clothes, candles. And I've been telling
her she's got to do that on our channel.
And I have some people have
learned that I have quite the skin care
routine as well. So
>> So to answer your question, yes,
there'll be a little bit of health talk
stuff.
>> And she has completely fixed me since
the old Little Light days when I was
Yeah. If you go back and watch Marvel,
not Satan's Endgame, I'm like poor
girl.
Um, I'm still not where I want to be,
but I don't have, you know, I hate to
even say I don't have time to exercise.
That's the biggest, you know, lamest
excuse. But, uh, right this moment, I
just don't, if I get into an exercise
routine, I can see good results quick.
>> But right now, Aubry's just done a great
job on our diet. We are
most of the time vegan,
gluten-free,
low salt, low sugar, low oil.
And that's that's not 100% of the time.
We are 100% of the time vegetarian. We
don't eat meat at all.
>> But uh and there's, you know, when we
travel a lot, it's hard to stick with
that diet. You cannot
>> I mean, people don't have dairy free and
gluten-free and all this stuff. So, a
lot of times when we travel, which is a
lot,
>> we don't always get to stick to that
diet, but when we do, it actually it's
very helpful.
>> Um, let's see. I'm I'm clicking these
and reading them like live. Like I have
you seen the David Knight show on
Rumble. Alex Jones calls the vaccine
sugar water. Said Bill Gates and Trump
got us the goods. God bless. Wait, what?
Bill Gates and Trump got us the good
mix. Sugar water.
>> I'm not sure I understand that.
>> Yeah, I'm kind of confused on that. I do
think
when it comes to the subject of the V, I
believe that some were placebo and some
were really bad and it was like a big
uh a big experiment. And you don't just
rush out something called, you know,
project warp speed and then start
injecting people with it and almost
making it like mandatory.
>> There's been hidden cameras on um hidden
camera interviews with the people from
Fizer and and now Johnson and Johnson as
well. These guys openly admit that we
were told to make make a vaccine and we
have to in this amount of time and we
did and there was no testing and we're
only on lab rats and I mean it it's out
now. The cat's out of the bag. Like this
stuff was not safe, not effective. They
said it's 100% safe, 100% effective.
Sign this waiver. That was a red flag
right there. If you haven't seen the
documentary, I don't even know if I can
say this phrase because it we it'll get
censored big time, but uh what was it
even?
Died
suddenly.
If you watch them, if you go to Rumble
and look up what I just said, um there
are
corners. Is that what they call? the the
people that like the autopsy people that
work at
>> corners. Yeah.
>> Dude, they were pulling fibers out of
people's arteries that looked like rope,
>> white rope,
>> saying, "I've never seen anything like
this in my life." And and I'm getting
people left and right with this in it.
>> So, I I highly recommend watching that
documentary.
>> Um,
love the channel. Thank you so much.
Quintes
Butterfly says, "Hey guys, I've been
curious as to how referring to Ellen
White stuff so often isn't an issue. Is
it some how stepping out of the Bible?
Shouldn't we refer
to just that for answers?" I don't ever
talk about Ellen White. We did one
video.
>> We don't refer to her.
Um, I heard about her prophetic vision
about um, Nashville being destroyed,
specifically fireball from heaven
hitting the Parthonon building. And we
went to Nashville to see this Parthonon
building
>> and a 40 foot golden goddess of Athena
there. And I'm like, wow, yeah, I could
totally see this happening. And
>> we only spoke about Ellen White because
she was the one who had a prophecy, a
vision of what was going to happen
there.
>> Yeah. So
>> yeah, if it would have been any anyone
else that had a prophetic vision about
that, I would have quoted them and said
>> somebody had a had a vision and they the
thing is is this vision was like
in the 1904
>> and I don't even know if those if that
building was there at the time, but she
was in Nashville. she saw a building
with pillars all the way around that
were casted, not sculpted. And that's
the only building that fits that
criteria
and um
and it has a 40ft golden goddess in
there. And so, you know, if anyone from
1904, anyone else, I don't care who it
was, had a had a vision of that, that
would intrigue me. And when the vision
said that people were saying you knew
and didn't tell us, why didn't you say
anything? To me, that convicted me like,
if this is true, I want to I'm not going
to have other people's blood on my hands
and not at least tell it.
>> So, I used our platform,
the the small platform we have to share
a potentially true, I believe true
because
>> everything lines up.
>> Yeah, it is. It is a satanic
place right there. And why did she have
a vision? I don't think she's um you
know, a lot of people
think that she's something, I don't
know, witch or something. This is a
woman that spent the majority of her
entire life writing commentaries about
the Bible, uh devotions, pointing people
to Christ in the Bible and away from
tradition. She was like, "We need to
keep the Sabbath. We need to eat
according to the the plant-based diet
that God created for us in and the
Garden of Eden.
>> I think that leads us back to what we're
gonna say is that everything she wanted
people to do is go to the Bible for
answers really and that's what we do.
>> Yep.
>> So,
>> if you find any other Ellen White on our
channel, let me know because I think one
other time I mentioned it on an alien
thing that she said in the last days
heathen deities will manifest. And I
believe that's true as well. I believe
it's literally happening right now. So,
so twice ever in a year of making
content, she consistently
>> quoted her, but
>> it's all Bible for us. Everything I
believe I can prove from the Bible
alone.
>> But I do think some of those prophetic
um
prophetic visions or whatever about some
of the things that are happening now are
interesting. So, I bring them up.
Uh,
>> lifting the veil said, "Are you guys
going to Truth or Con in October?" Yes,
that's a great question. We are actually
going to be speaking at a couple events
coming up. The the very next one,
>> where's the truth?
>> Is Conspira or Espiracy Con, which is
such a cool name because it's like
conspiracy, but Spiracy Con. I'm gonna
stretch this out since we're not on
camera anyway.
So, Spiracy Con, dude, you guys have to
come to this. There's going to be so
many great speakers. It's August 22nd
and 23rd in Cave City, Kentucky.
That that is exactly a month away.
Exactly a month from today. If you guys
buy tickets, please use our uh
recommendation or whatever it's called.
These are the speakers. You got Aaron
Judkins.
>> How do they do that?
>> Oh, I'll show you.
>> Okay.
>> So, if you guys aren't familiar with Now
You See TV. They got some great videos.
Um I don't agree with anyone 100% on
anything. So, before you guys start
saying, "Oh, they believe in the Little
Season and all that." I already know. um
they are
>> this is just a platform that we're being
invited to speak on as well to share
truth and so
>> this is us um widening our horizons
>> and I do really like some of the stuff
that they put out too so he's he's one
of the main speakers on now you see TV
>> um Charlie Raymond
actually I don't know a lot of these
people but John Pounders
him and the older gentleman right here
David they are the two that um basically
run now you see TV. I saw we got a
thumbs down. Thanks for that guys. Uh if
you guys want to give a thumbs up or
thumbs down or comment really helps this
video get into the algorithm. So more
speakers will be added soon. They're
actually already on here. Here's all the
speakers.
>> Okay.
>> And you'll see Oh, Mikey Jenny right
there. Look at this picture of me, guys.
>> Look at that. That's not me. Who is
that?
Okay, that's enough.
>> Who is that? That's hilarious. Anyway,
I'll be there talking about umnosticism
in Hollywood because these guys are
covering everything. I wanted to talk
about aliens, but somebody's already
talking about aliens apparently. So,
>> then
uh this was the question that came up.
Truth or con? So, this is in a month. If
you guys want to buy tickets, click
tickets and make sure that you Oh, so I
sold out of VIP. Make sure that you
How'd you hear about us? Make sure you
click Truth, guys.
>> It's right there.
>> Yeah, make sure you click this because
we actually will get a commission from
that and that would help out greatly.
So, if you guys want to support this
ministry, but you can't give a donation,
but you plan on being at this event,
please buy a ticket and just click
Candid Truth and we will actually get a
little bit of commission from that.
Thank you guys so much for that. So,
that's next month in a month.
>> Then there's Truth or Con.
>> Truther Con October
25th through 26 and it's in Dallas. Just
to remind you guys, this one is in
Kentucky. It's only three hours from
where we live, Kentucky. This one's
gonna be in Dallas, Texas. Truther Con.
>> Okay.
>> Um, I don't know that they've updated
the speakers, but Dave Weiss is going to
be there. That's what's up. I know Josh
from Founded Earth Brothers is going to
be there. Let's see. Special guest.
Yep. Found Earth and Lifting the Veil is
gonna be there. Found Earth Brothers.
Lifting the Veil
>> and we're not on here yet. Somebody's
not keeping the site updated.
>> And then
and what month is this?
Uh November. November 7th, 8th, and 9th
in Courtsite, Arizona
is the International Truth Expo. Dude,
there are some great speakers at this
one. Um, Mark Sergeant, the one and only
Mark Sergeant.
Um, DJ Curious, who's always hanging out
with Mark Sergeant on Strange World.
Burn the Corporate Fiction. Oo, that's
going to be very interesting. Nathan
Thompson,
you guys know him. Candid Truth. Mike
and Aubrey going to be there. So, here's
all the people. Oh, man. Ace Baker. If
you guys never saw this documentary,
911, Great American Sai Opera, it is the
best 911 documentary on Earth. And Dave
Weiss.
So, yep. That's in um
November 7th and 8th and 9th in Arizona
and that is called the International
Truth Expo. So, here's what here's what
they are. Spiracy Con,
>> Truthcon,
>> Truthcon.com,
and International Truth Expo. We really
hope to see you guys there.
Do you celebrate God's festivals or
feast? I have never celebrated a feast.
I'm not against it. I never done it
before. We keep the Sabbath
>> every Friday evening. The Saturday
evening
and I'm open to the feast. I um we don't
keep holidays. We don't keep any of the,
you know, pagan holidays that most
people keep. And so you do kind of have
a void there. And you're like, man, I
wish we could do something to hang out
with people. And I hear that some of
these feasts are like camping out in
tents and
um hanging out for a couple days. But
no, good question.
I know a lot of people though that do.
Let's see. Oops. The David Knight show.
Um,
I love John Rich's song Revelation.
Let me answer that one. The second
coming is the rapture. That's exactly
correct.
We will also see tribulation. That's
exactly correct.
Christians are not going to magically
disappear
before the tribulation starts. So, man,
I think we're way behind on these
comments here. Let's see.
>> Yeah, we are.
>> The fifth trumpet. Let's see. The fifth
trumpet has to do with Earth getting hit
by a large burning rock like an
asteroid, possibly.
>> I'm not sure where that's coming from.
>> Yeah, I'm not I'm not familiar with
that. Um,
>> I do think that we are behind.
>> Oh, yeah. It's the seventh. It's the
seventh trump. Yep.
Uh, okay. This is a good question. Live
out the chaos says, "What's your take on
the book of Enoch where it says it was
actually fallen angels breeding with
humans? Is that biblical?"
I would say no. And so, a lot of people
are going to disagree. A lot of people
that uh I'm friends with will disagree.
I do not believe the book of Enoch is
canon.
>> I read it back in 2012. At that time I
was very intrigued, very interested and
believed a lot differently than I do
today. Um but
>> we
let's say I have um been researching
some of that and there will probably be
a show on that soon.
>> Yeah. So
when when Jesus was questioned by the
Pharisees, this woman was married, her
husband died, she married his brother as
the custom was. He died and it happened
seven times. She married seven of his
brothers. She said or they asked him in
the resurrection whose wife will she be?
Jesus said
um you don't understand the scriptures
like after the resurrection after the
resurrection
we will not give in marriage we will
become like the angels and so
>> it explains what the angels are like
>> yeah Jesus said right there that they
don't give in marriage and what's the
purpose of marriage be fruitful and
multiply populate the earth and all that
right and man should not be alone and
all that
>> but in the Bible you You don't see a
single female angel anywhere. It's
always, you know, two men in white
apparel or whatever. Angels
were created before earth was created
because they rejoiced when they saw
earth being created. So if God created
a bunch, there's a lot of angels, tons
of them. If God created,
let's just say billions of immortal
males,
who are not flesh and blood. We do not
battle against flesh and blood, but
against principalities. We're told
they're not flesh and blood.
Do they have spermbearing testicles?
>> No.
>> If so, why? There's no marriage, there's
no women, there's no
procreation.
So, if they're not flesh and blood,
they're all males, they're all immortal,
there's no need for
>> or way to do that.
>> Yeah. and no sperm bearing testicles.
Now,
are there cases of people being sexually
assaulted by demons and stuff?
Absolutely. Yeah, they're shape
shifters. They can
>> shape shift into a serpent or into some
other kind of penetrating whatever.
>> They could possess a man who is under
their influence during that moment,
>> but it will not be a demon's child or a
Nephilim's child that you'll have. It'll
be that man's offspring
>> of the rapist.
>> So to answer the question about the
Nephilim and all that, when you read the
Bible, it says it's explaining that the
sons of God came into the daughters of
men.
>> And when you read the Bible
all the way through, you'll see over and
over and over that the sons of God are
those who follow God. Mhm.
>> Um it says that we become that do you
not know you have the power to become
the sons of God and all this stuff. The
sons of God are believers. The daughters
of men which most of the Bible doesn't
refer to the daughters of men but it
talks about the sons of men. The sons of
men are non-believers. The sons of
daughters or the daughters of men would
be non-believers. So
>> the gentile women basically or the
foreign women,
>> right? The whole context of
>> that, by the way, God already told them
not to marry.
>> Yeah. The whole context of Genesis 6 is
saying, "Do not uh do not be unequally
yolked." Why? Because it always led to
disaster.
And so that did happen. And they,
you know, and then it read when you read
on, it says there were giants in the
earth in those days. It doesn't say they
gave birth to giants because they were
alien or they were angel hybrid. It
doesn't say that.
>> There's no punctuation in the original
Greek and Hebrew. You're just reading it
and it's saying the sons of God came
into the daughters of men. There were
giants in those days. We know there were
giants in those days. We saw that they
were in the promised land, right? There
was Goliath and all that stuff. It says
in those days and also after that they
were men of renown and all this stuff.
Mhm.
>> But it's not making a direct correlation
that these an angels mated with women
and created these giants.
>> It doesn't it doesn't say that.
>> Um the reason I don't believe in the
book of Enoch is because what I know
about what happens when you die. When
you're dead, you're dead until the
resurrection. The resurrection isn't
here yet. The judgment isn't here yet.
Mhm.
>> And so when I read the book of Enoch and
it says that he saw the disembodied
spirit of Abel, that is spiritualism.
That's not biblical at all.
>> That belief has crept into the church.
And many people today think that you can
talk to your dead loved ones because
they're not really dead. They're still
alive somewhere. They're either burning
in hell for eternity or they're in
heaven. And um so Enoch saw the
disembodied spirit of Abel. But we know
that the spirit is the breath of life
that returns back to God who gave it
when you die. Your body returns to the
dust of the earth. Your breath returns
to God. You're dead until
um Christ returns and the dead in Christ
shall rise first. That the graves will
open up. Many uh Daniel says that many
will awaken out of the dust of the earth
to judgment to either eternal life or
eternal contempt. So that's another
reason I reject the book of Enoch as
well as Enoch was flying over uh a place
that's like hell like where people are
being tortured in fire. I don't believe
in that concept of hell. Well, hell is
not happening because when you're dead,
you're dead. And at the at the judgment
after the thousand years, the the wicked
will be judged and they're going to be
tossed into the lake of fire, which is
the second death, and they're going to
be annihilated, totally extinct. They're
going to be God isn't giving the wicked
eternal life to burn for eternity. He's
only giving the gift of everlasting life
to the righteous. The wicked receive the
second death, which is eternal, and
they're gone. And that hasn't happened
yet. And therefore, I don't know what
Enoch was supposedly seeing when he's
flying with this angel over this hellish
place.
>> I will I was going to say something, but
I will leave it for that show when we
cover it.
>> It's going to be a good show. We got
some We do have some good stuff lined
up, guys. I'm
>> on that. I'm doing some final edits on a
video that's like a produced video that
Aubrey did. Um,
>> I've been busy, you guys.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm putting together the the
slides for the topic of hell. That hell
is not an eternal place of torment. That
it is actually
annihilation of the wicked. God is not
preserving sin for all eternity. He's
getting rid of it. So, that will come
up. Uh, let's see. Caleb says, "Have you
ever asked yourself why we don't obey
the Torah apart from obvious laws like
sacrificial or why we pick what ones to
go by?"
Matthew 5:17.
Also, we are to walk as Christ walked.
Why not walk Torah? Yeah, why not walk
Torah? What would change in our life if
we walk Torah
>> versus God's Bible?
>> I would say we really do. That's kind of
the argument that people have
in the quote unquote Torah community is
that we keep a lot of these laws
naturally. They're sanitation laws. A
lot of the laws don't even apply to
everybody. It's like this only applies
if you're a farmer. This only applies if
you're female. This only applies if
you're a priest or whatever. So,
>> plus I know people say that a lot, but
that would end up being like what
thousands of laws again.
>> Well, that's what people say, like 800
laws. But
>> that is not what God I believe meant for
a life of freedom and love from him.
>> Well, those 800 laws are
laws that we keep naturally though. It's
like how to wash your hands, don't
touch.
>> I have heard that. But there are some
that of course we don't. But
>> some are like don't don't trim the edges
of your beard and stuff like that. But
that was talking about not doing as the
pagans do. You look at that statue of
Nebuchadnezzar, he's got this like real
squared off beard and stuff.
>> But I do know that keeping the law to a
tea like that,
>> let's be honest, the Pharisees and
Sadducees did it that way. Your faith
will become dry as a bone. It's numbing.
You do not love your Lord, your God. I
believe when you're doing that. And so
I have to have a life where because I
came from a very relig I shouldn't say
this, but I came from a very legalistic
family. Um, and
it was really the fact that you couldn't
even, you know, it's it was an Adventist
family and reform Adventist. My
grandparents were pastor uh he was a
pastor and then pastor's wife and you
couldn't even wade in water up to your
ankles was like all you could do on the
Sabbath.
>> And so I had all these extra rules on me
that really quite honestly when you read
the Bible it's not there
>> and I get that. And so my heart any
child who's raised that way is going to
hate the Sabbath. It's going to hate the
Bible. I believe they're going to hate
God.
And so I don't think that's going to be
helpful in their life. And maybe I'm
getting too deep into that, but most of
the time it is true that they are they
have the wrong kind of worship of God
also in that respect in my opinion.
>> So I do believe that the Pharisees were
adding to the law. They were keeping
>> the what is it the Tanakh or something
or the
>> well you have the Torah the Midash the
um there's several Toras I don't know if
you guys know that but it's actually
that becomes cabalism as well
>> which is not of God. Well, that's what I
believe that they were Cabalas basically
>> and they were keeping laws that weren't
even laws. Like
>> you can't walk so many steps on the
Sabbath and you can't carry a tray, but
you can get your gentile friend or the
lowly
>> dog to do it.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I'm not against keeping the 800
laws. I don't know that there are any
that I'm breaking or anything. So, I'm
>> That's what I'm saying. I think we keep
them. We
>> wear 100% cotton. We know this is all
health sanitation.
How to make how to keep your garden from
like depleting of minerals and a lot of
stuff we keep already.
>> I'm sure we do keep a lot of them
naturally, but
>> never looked into them too deeply like
that.
>> So, Ace says, "Hello, Mikey and Aubrey
Q&A question. Have you seen the trend on
the laboo dolls?" Yes,
these things are completely satanic.
Stay away from them. I don't I can't
believe that this thing's taken off. But
I guess it's no different than when we
grew up with the troll dolls, the naked
trolls with the tall hair. They make
them look so cute. They're ugly. Ugly
and cute. But
>> and apparently they're really popular
with adults,
>> but that's because they were There's
like a whole satanic thing going on with
this doll. According to what Mikey
found, I hope you don't mind me being
the one to say it.
>> No, go for it. I don't know what you
should say.
>> They're actually
they represent a demon. They actually
they
>> admit that.
>> Yeah.
>> That they were made after demons. And so
people have the supernatural connection.
It's like attachment that they're going
crazy over.
>> Yeah.
>> And for one, getting in line and waiting
all night and all this stuff. And then
>> they have to have it at all times. It's
like their safety net. Um, so there is
something supernatural and wrong, like
very demonic about these dolls. That's
>> it's idol.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh, I like this one. Do you guys eat the
biblical antibiotics, onions, and
garlic? The rawer the better. Yes. I
knocked this thing out.
>> I I wasn't really thinking because I was
like, "Ah, it's going to be gone
tomorrow. It's gonna be gone tomorrow."
>> And it finally got worse and I was like,
"Okay, I'm not playing around." And I
ate like huge chunks of garlic cloves.
And then I put I took a mug and I put
like a bunch of turmeric turmeric.
Turmeric. Turmeric. What do you want to
call it?
>> Turmeric.
>> And and black pepper and like just
barely put any water in it. Chugged a
shot of it. The next day I did it again.
Oh yeah. I was drinking ginger. Ginger,
tumeric, black pepper, and garlic. I did
that for two days straight back to back
and it just knocked it out, man.
Actually, when I chewed the garlic, my
sinuses just went like opened up. So,
definitely do that.
>> Here's my brother right here walking
with Yahwa. This is my brother Britain.
I was just talking about you, man. I
can't remember why though what we were
talking about. Oh, I said you I said
you'd probably be in here because we
were just on the phone talking.
Uh Aubrey, you always have glowing skin.
mind sharing your skincare routine if
you have any?
>> Um,
well, I could, but it would take some
time. Like, it's not it's it's all using
homemade things or things around the
house, but it's um
it's not really intuitive to a lot of
people. It's very interesting. He can
even vouch for that. I've been doing
some skin care on him.
>> That's why he might look a little
>> I'm glowing. I'm actually glowing
because our air conditioner doesn't work
and it's very hot.
>> All right. And when we do shows,
>> we're going to do a donations for fixing
the central air in this house.
>> When we do shows, we have to turn off
all the noise. So then again, we can't
have fans and we can't have anything
that cools us. So then we get to glisten
y
>> in front of the camera. Also, you
>> see that sweat rolling?
>> I don't sweat as much. I love the heat.
So, I'm not sweaty. This is me. You're
correct. Um, so I can cover that for
you,
>> my skincare routine in more depth later,
but I I just don't think I should do
that right now because it would take
some time.
>> Well, I could share some of it.
>> No, no, let's not do that.
>> Okay.
>> Not right now.
>> Um,
walking with Yahweh says, "Because the
God of this world has blinded them."
That's absolutely true. That was in
response to why you think people are
close-minded about this stuff or
whatever. Is it just me or do Wait, is
it just me or do I look like Chopped
Liver right now? Mikey, I don't know.
Did you Was your question about me doing
a song?
I I I responded to that before we
started that. Uh that's a pretty tall
order. I don't know um how I can
>> squeeze that in.
>> Yeah. work on music right now. I'm I
can't even keep a video a week coming
out right now.
>> We struggled. I mean, you guys don't
even know this, but what
>> I didn't even talk about that. You guys
don't know a lot of the stuff we do
behind the scenes. This is me at a
nursing home. The nursing home that my
mother passed away in in March.
And I've been going here every month for
the past 3 months giving presentations.
You can see some people are falling
asleep.
>> Um, but yeah, so we do things. We're not
just, you know, sitting around in our
PJs looking up videos like, "Hey, let's
let's do a topic on that or whatever."
Like, we are out here doing stuff. even
in our local community, like going to
the nursing home where people need to
hear the truth, too. They have families.
They they might be old, but they need
the truth and they want to share the
truth. And so, I've had the blessing of
getting to come out here. I don't have
pictures of the other times that I was
there. But um I've been out there three
times and more to come sharing out
there,
going to events, going to churches. Um
actually this Sabbath I'll be doing a
presentation for a church in Australia
over Zoom. So there's a lot of Zoom
stuff going on. There's a lot of going
to churches to speak for either Sabbath
or the weekend. and then these events
that we just showed you guys coming up.
So, we're busy.
>> We have a lot of
>> They're not all paid events either.
>> We have other bookings of course from
other local, not just local, but
churches all over the world even that
are booking us like you said in
Australia, Alaska. Mikey speaks to
churches all over.
>> Um, of course, some of those are over
Zoom, but
we have quite a filled schedule.
>> Uh, let's see. Of course not. It's just
Of course not. It's just sad. No, I'm
not the only one that sees the maybe
entertaining but useless channels with
millions of subscribers and you know
they're making big money. Yeah,
definitely. If they have
>> 500,000 subs,
yeah, they're they're probably making
some good money on those uh ads. I'm
actually glad that we don't have ads on
our channel, but it would be helpful a
little bit. It'd probably only be like
$300 a month or something.
Let's see. Rocket said, "We have
chemtrails over our skies here in
Arizona all the time. It's hideous."
Yeah, it comes and goes, man. Sometimes
here it's like
looks like a spiderweb out there and a
net and then a and then there's times
where nothing happens. But we've been
getting in the Tennessee area, we've
been getting tornatic tornat tornatic
winds and rain.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Winds and rains are knocking trees
over literally from the roots. Trees
just like everywhere.
>> We also have rumblings and in the sky
like it's going to be thunder and
lightning, but it's not.
>> Yeah.
>> Um I know that's
>> I don't think any of this stuff's
natural, man. Yeah.
>> Oh, Taylor said, "Literally the cutest
couple." I agree.
God has blessed
Aubrey so much with me. And God's
blessed me so much. I never dreamed I
could have a wife that believed and
thought the way I do and we're just
>> perfectly connected on all that. I love
it.
>> Uh, yeah. Who knows? Let's see. Yeah,
who knows what they're doing to the
weather.
these days. That's true. If you think
that they can't control the weather,
think again. I mean, this has been going
on for a long time. Look up HARP H a RP.
And uh they have lots of ways they could
do it. Cloud seating,
um
ultra low frequencies underground to
cause earthquakes, all kinds of stuff.
It's really simple stuff, too.
>> They just have the money to make it
happen.
Question.
Did you guys watch the missionaries that
Brad had on Strange Normal last week?
The video that he put out, if you
haven't watched it, it was amazing and I
believe that all churches should be
showing it. Awesome. Thank you for
giving me that uh recommendation. I
don't always get to keep up with Brad's
channel. I love getting to be on there.
I love the conversations we have. We're
actually be hanging out next weekend at
an event coming up and uh in Florida, so
that's going to be fun. But yes, I'll
definitely have to check that out. I
know that he had a guy on I didn't know
if it was a couple or missionaries, but
I know that he had a guy on there that
was like seeing some demonic stuff.
>> Uh let's get some likes going. Thank
you, Ace. Yes. One easy, free, simple
way to help this ministry is to give it
a thumbs up right now. Boom. Just click
that thumbs up. I know sometimes we
watch videos, we don't even think about
it, but it really does help get it out
into the algorithm. There's 71 people in
here. 54 thumbs up and one thumbs down.
So, thank you for that. Um, we got to
trust them for sure.
saying, let's see, some people rather
continue believing the lie than hear
that they were lied to.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> And that they believe the lies. It's so
true. I mean,
>> I've always been a truth seeker, so I've
just I've always wanted to know the
truth, but I know my dad often just says
like, "Everything I believe was a lie."
And he like upsets him and and then he
just accepts the reality. But he wants
to know the truth. I love that my dad is
like telling me he said, "You know what?
I just been praying to God more and
more. Whatever the truth is, even if
it's so controversial, even if it goes
against everything I've ever believed, I
want to know truth." And that's my
prayer. I don't care if the truth goes
against everything I've ever believed to
be true. I want to know the truth.
Aubrey,
so they basically don't read their Bible
the way it was written then. Yep. I
guess you'd have to say that about most
people. Yes.
>> Yep. They just believe what they hear in
church.
>> I'm not sure what that was pertaining
to, by the way. But in general, yes.
>> I started noticing chemtrails 15 or 16
years ago. Wow. For me, it was 2011 and
it was definitely a God thing. Like my
car broke down and it was overheated and
I had to sit in this parking lot
and I just happened to be in a place
that wasn't the city. So there wasn't
buildings in the way, there wasn't trees
in the way, mountains, none of that.
Open field and I just sitting here
watching these planes leave these long
trails and they were just capturing my
attention. And I noticed like an hour, I
don't know if it was an hour, but
minutes later, however long it was
taking to let the car cool down. I was
like, "Those things look like they're
coming down or something." Like they
were getting so big and so wide that I
literally thought they were like
>> dropping getting closer.
>> They weren't dissipating. They were
growing. I was like
>> descending upon you.
>> Yeah.
>> But that was what caught my attention
like why is this condensation not
dissipating? Why is it growing? The only
thing that grows
>> Mhm.
>> is a chemical combination. Think about
baking soda and vinegar. You mix them
together and it it grows. Right.
>> Right.
>> And I was like that doesn't look right.
And it caught my attention so much that
I mentioned it to my dad and he was
like, yeah, they call them chemtrails.
He'd happened to be hearing about it on
on his third shift uh listening to a
radio station called Coast to Coast AM
with George Nory and they talk about all
kinds of conspiracy stuff.
Whatever happened to that Matt guy that
you and Brad used to talk with? Good
question. I don't
>> I actually don't know Matt. I think I
might know Matt, but I didn't actually
do a lot of shows with him. Um if it's
the Matt I'm thinking of.
>> Not sure. I don't know what happened.
That's a good question. Um,
you will know them by their fruits.
Absolutely. You will not know them just
because they say they are Christian.
Let's see. I heard about cloud seeding
from the Texas floods. That's not
something we should be doing. Yeah. No,
we should not be messing with God's
>> creation.
>> Yeah. Like
>> nature.
>> Wow. Yeah. Messing with nature like
that.
Good point, brother. I wish I knew what
point that was. I don't know how far
behind I am on these harp is dangerous.
Absolutely.
>> How do you think AI will be implemented
in these last days? A lot of people
believe it will be the last days.
Deception merging human with AI.
>> Well,
>> I mean, I think AI is going to be used
to enslave humanity. It's going to be
used to
watch every move you make. Now you don't
have to hire security guards sleeping
behind a desk watching monitors. I mean,
it's AI never sleeps. Um, also
it's getting to be where you can't tell
the difference in real life and AI
anymore. So easily blackmail any person.
I mean, you could put you could take the
most Christlike person like Daniel who
never did anything. They had to
blackmail him by they had to set him up
by by making him arrest be arrested for
praying to his god, you know,
>> and that's a really good example because
that that is will it where it will go
to, but it we're not there yet. So, we
need to just keep it is a tool that even
we can use to glorify God.
>> Y
>> if we use it the right way, excuse me.
>> Every tool can be used for good or for
evil, whether it's TV,
>> even a gun or whatever. You know, you
can use it to uh
shoot a
a can. I don't know. Shoot a a wolf
that's trying to kill your family or
something. I don't know. Or you can use
it to murder people. Uh they've been
cloud seen for a long time.
>> Can we skip down to
>> I'm not going to skip people's questions
if they got questions.
>> These aren't questions.
>> They might be. From a Christian biblical
standpoint, what's your take on
vaccines, especially the types used to
prevent childhood illness like smallox,
tetanus, etc. I say avoid any vaccine.
I've thought this since 2012.
My daughter has not had a vaccine. We
got the religious exemption back when
she first started school back in She's
14 now.
>> Lucky. So,
yeah, we've had we have immune systems.
We've been surviving for thousands of
years without injecting ourselves with
man-made chemicals and who knows what
else, mercury and fetal tissue and all
that. I don't I don't mess with any of
that ever.
>> It's not necessary. No.
>> No. I stick with God's natural remedies.
Uh mean what you say and say what you
mean. Just don't be mean when you say
it. That's a good one for having tacked.
Uh, it's too hot to exercise. Oh, I
agree with you there.
>> I disagree, but that's me.
>> Yeah,
>> I love working out, too.
>> Let's see. Uh, they are bad out here.
Come.
>> How long have you been married? Well,
April will be two years, but April's
still a ways away, right? We're in July.
June, March, July.
>> Wait, it was November.
>> That was already
>> So, November.
Okay.
>> Yeah,
>> we have the date that we officially got
married in God's sight and then it took
us a while to be able to get it on
paper. So I
>> and actually get the paper from the
courthouse. So
>> yeah, but November. So November coming
up is two years.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. November.
Uh good question. Let's see. A lot of
people think I'm not stupid. Wait, a lot
of people think I'm not stupid. I don't
care. I know it's real. I know demons
are real. And if
anybody reads The Arrival,
they should know that, too. That's why
I'm so dumbfounded at the church. Yeah,
I know. Like I'm dumbfounded, too. I
think I think the church, you know, the
Bible talks about Jesus talked about a
parable of the 10 virgins that fell
asleep.
>> They were all virgins. They all had oil.
They were all Christians with the Holy
Spirit, but they all fell asleep. All 10
of them. And then they all woke up, but
only five had enough oil or Holy Spirit
to get to the wedding. The other five
were like trying to get, "Can you give
me some?" and they were like, "If we
give you some of ours, we won't make
it." So, those five went back to try and
buy some oil. And it was too late. And I
believe that's where we're at 100%. That
um the church is asleep. We know, we
should know things that are happening.
There's all kinds of prophecies in the
Bible and,
you know, things that we've learned over
the years studying prophecy. And yet the
church is asleep.
I don't mean just y'all.
Haha. I've
>> This is really
>> Other people mention her a good bit. Oh.
Oh, other people. Yeah. I don't know.
You know, I don't I don't think Ellen
White said anything that I really
disagree with, honestly. I mean, I I
think she was a genuine
god-loving woman. She woke up to
tradition is not of God,
>> came to the truth of the Sabbath and
>> but she is not the Bible and she's not
God. So
>> yeah,
>> as we said before, we are going to be
teaching from directly the straight
truth.
>> Yep.
>> Which is the Bible,
>> Bible, history, current events,
whatever. But um I think she had a lot
of good things to say and I think she
>> is
judged a lot and people don't even know
why. You know, even I did it. I was
like, I'm not going to listen to
anything this because, you know, when
people start saying stuff like she's a
prophet and stuff like that, that's
those are like always a red flag when
you're looking at, you know, churches
and people who attend a certain church.
If they have a prophet, you're just
like, "Yep." But I haven't really
I haven't dug deep in her writings, but
I everything I've read seems to be
pointing people to Christ in the Bible.
Did you hear about Ozie Osborne dying? I
did. As well as um the guy who played
Theo on on uh Cosby Show.
>> Yeah,
>> they're back to back. One day apart.
Well, I
I hate to be around when judgment day
comes for Aussie, man. Let's see. Uh I
don't think there's a problem with
referring to LG White. Let's not be
petty.
>> Okay. Uh not being petty
was generally curious because we were
told to look elsewhere for answers. So,
it was curious.
>> We were told not to look elsewhere.
Yeah.
Everything I believe 100% I can prove
from the Bible. Everything. Why I
believe the Sabbath, why I believe
uh the who the antichrist is, what
happens when you die, all that straight
from the Bible.
>> It is folly not to hear a matter. Amen.
LG White takes everything from the
Bible. That's why SDAs believe she was a
prophetic prophetical. Good word. I
never heard that one. prophetical
messenger.
Uh, imagine believing the Bible is the
absolute truth. Yeah. What do you
believe? An Odin or something. Um, I do
believe the Bible's absolute truth
because it's been proven over and over.
>> No man has ever been able to destroy the
Bible. It's been tried, but for it's it
stood the test of time, and people
thousands by the thousands and millions
have died for it. Let's see. The Bible
is a Jewish scout.
>> Oh my.
>> How so? Because
if you believe the Bible and understand
the Bible, you'll know that the who the
people that we call Jews today are not
even Jews and they are cabalist and they
rule the world and it has nothing to do
with believing in Jesus. They reject
Jesus. They literally reject the Christ,
the Messiah. How can it be a Jewish
sciop when
>> the Jews rejected Jesus? The one that
the Bible talks about.
>> Uh, so I guess she was a prophet. Let's
see. Scrolling through. Shalom, girl.
Let's see.
The sayith the Lord, I'm sure. Okay.
Looks like a lot about white.
Um,
second Samuel. Weird. The Bible calls
Yahweh Satan.
So, the origin says the Bible calls
Yahweh Satan. I'm glad you're here, man.
This is awesome to have you, somebody
that doesn't even believe the Bible in
here. It's pretty pretty awesome. Uh,
did you hear an Instant Pot go off?
>> No, that's our de dehumidifier
room.
>> Yeah, we got to have dehumidifiers right
now.
>> Sabbath is gay. Why is that? You don't
like resting
one day a week. Feel sorry for you.
I've read a lot.
>> Deborah
>> Deborah says, "I've read a lot of what
Ellen White wrote, but I don't put her
before my Bible." Amen. Right.
>> Feast days and the other Sabbaths were
nailed to the cross. Chadwick says,
"A lot of people believe that. I don't I
just don't see that it's problematic or
anything but to keep the feast days. Uh
do you understand the meaning of using
some meaning of using something as a
reference?
>> I think we do it all the time.
>> Yeah.
Okay. Let's see. Are there any other
questions?
>> We really need Yeah. questions if anyone
has
>> I'm glad you guys are having a you know
conversation there. 78 people. Thank you
so much for being in here. I didn't
expect a lot of people to really be in
for this. I'm glad though that we get to
connect with you guys, tell you what
we're up to, that we can't do this
without you. That Oh man, I almost wish
I could just show you guys the studio.
>> I could really get candid with it.
>> Please don't.
>> What? What do you mean?
Uh, let's see. Does Okay. Does Aubrey
believe Oh, this is just for you. Does
Oliver believe in father and son or
trinity?
>> Well,
I
believe what the Bible says.
>> So, this is a super triggering topic
and I do think it's an important topic.
I used to not think so. I used to think,
you know what,
whether you believe in the father and
the son and and the the spirit of God,
those three, or if you believe in the
trinity and the third person, the holy
spirit is the third person. It's not
going to affect our salvation. You know,
one day we're going to get there and
we're going to find out. There's going
to be a lot of people in heaven or in
the new earth that kept Sunday every
week. They never kept a Sabbath in their
life. There's going to be people there
that didn't know the true name of God.
There's going to be people there that
believed in the Trinity or a different
different belief. Um, I'm thankful that
God judges us where we're at. He knows
that if we're earnestly seeking truth
with all our hearts and we're digging
for it in the word of God, we're all in
different parts of our walk. There's
some people that think the earth is a
spinning ball. There's some people that
think um
all kinds of different things that hell
is eternal torment, that when you die,
you go straight to heaven.
But these are things that we're we're
learning along the way. The more you get
into truth, the more truth you find.
>> And there is a very good documentary
that just came out. It's actually from
kind of an Adventist offshoot, I guess.
and it's called
the Antichrist Spirit in Adventism.
Anybody can watch it. You don't have to
be an Adventist to watch it. The title
intrigued me. And they had some very
good verses in there. They had some very
good statements from people that founded
the church in the 1800s and stuff like
that.
And um I believe the stuff that's in
there. I believe those scriptures. I
believe those statements.
And I believe that the Holy Spirit is
the spirit of God, the spirit of Christ.
You either have the Holy Spirit, which
gives you the spirit to be holy and to
have victory in your life, or you have
another spirit, the spirit of
Antichrist, the spirit of lawlessness.
>> We can't do it on our own. We have to be
filled with the Holy Spirit, which is
the spirit of God, the spirit of Christ.
>> I think I know why some people are
asking that though, because we've had
that question. not necessarily directed
at me before, but after some of my pagan
origin.
>> Um,
>> there you go.
>> presentations. Mainly because people
start realizing that this mother,
father, son type cult relationship,
there's always the three
uh worshiped as one, you know, type of
deity is there. And I quite honestly,
I had to start looking into some of
that, too, because it is there. you're
always going to find that within
paganism.
And so
I I will just be honest, I have just
started looking into that topic myself
to flesh it out and I'm trying to
process it. Um,
and so yes, it was like you do find the
word trinity also not found in the Bible
or usually as a Christian thing, but as
a pagan thing that has been brought
along and that's just to say to put out
the facts before you. Mhm.
>> Um that
>> the facts are you're not going to find
the word trinity in the Bible
>> and you're only going to find it in the
pagan
um mythology that they've created where
like I said it's father son
father son and mother type of thing.
This yeah threein one type of a
situation. It doesn't have to be mother
and father and son but it can be like
three like the Celtic knot is actually
three goddesses together. Bridget,
Bridgette and Britney or something
together. Um,
and so yes, you're right. Like we have
gotten that question quite a bit from
those presentations. And I started
realizing I was saying it from just
giving the presentations quite a lot. I
realized what I was saying that it
always seems to be within these
mythologies.
>> Yeah. And so that's all I can leave you
with is that I'm looking into it myself
and what I believe on this topic just
now.
>> Yep. This is a great comment. It says,
"Why does it say don't you know the
scriptures?" This is referring back to
when they were asking Jesus whose wife
will she be. Um basically why did Jesus
say you don't know the scriptures? That
means there must be a scripture that
says angels are not given in marriage.
Only Enoch says that either we are
missing scriptures or Enoch is it. The
thing is is that's a direct
contradiction from the book of Enoch
though. If it says that angels don't
give in marriage and then it literally
says that they took wives.
How do you juggle that? People always
just say, "Well, the good ones, they
don't give in marriage." But that's not
what it says.
>> It says we become like the angels. They
do not give in marriage because why?
because they're immortal males with no
spermbearing genitals. And so,
>> and no wombs.
>> What Jesus is saying when he says, "You
don't know the scriptures," he's talking
about basically the the concepts that it
teaches. There's lots of things that the
Bible doesn't say anything about not
smoking marijuana, not not shooting up
heroin. You know, there's a lot of
things that are missing from the Bible
in a in a like direct reference way, but
we know what concepts the Bible teaches.
Be sober over and over and over. Do not
intoxicate your mind.
>> So, we can get concepts from the Bible
without it being like an exact
reference. Jesus didn't say according to
e, you know, first Enoch 8, it says that
angels don't give in marriage. He said,
you don't even know the scriptures.
We're not going to give in marriage
after the resurrection. We're going to
become like the angels who don't give in
marriage. So that's what I believe. I
believe if you think the other way, then
Enoch contradicts itself. There's a lot
of flaws in the book of Enoch. Like I
said, Abel, you know, Cain and Abel,
Abel does not have a disembodied spirit
that's alive right now. He's dead. The
dead know nothing. They will be
resurrected, awakened out of their
graves at the last trumpet when Jesus
comes back.
Um, there's no hell right now burning
there and people in there. And yet Enoch
was flying with an angel over hell.
I can't believe something that's
anti-biblical.
>> So, plus
there's a lot of different Enochs and,
you know, uh, Gnostics that were writing
things and they were signing it off as
as biblical writers so that it would
have more Yeah. So it have more
credibility like oh Enoch wrote this or
Paul wrote this or whatever.
Uh let's see
uh
even if you don't believe Enoch is
canon, Genesis is clear that it was
rebellious angels. You have to
reinterpret a lot of the scriptures to
believe that the sons of God were not
angels. I mean we can check it out. Um,
this is what I was hoping for to get to
do a little Bible study. So, let's see.
King James online.
Um,
so let's click this and let's search for
the term sons of God and look at the
context. So, this is, you know, Genesis
6 talks about the sons of God. Genesis 6
right here that the sons of God saw the
daughters of men that they were fair and
they took all them wives. They took them
wise of all which they chose. There were
giants in the earth in those days and
also thereafter when the sons of God
came into the daughters of men, they
bear children to them and the same
became mighty men, men of old which were
men of renown. So yeah, believers and
non-believers were mingling. They had
these great men, mighty men, men of
renown.
Um, Job does say the sons of God came to
present themselves before the Lord and
Satan also came among them. So, some
people say, "Hey, this is angels."
There's some other people that say these
were representatives of unfallen worlds.
We know that the Bible twice says that
God created all the worlds, created
frame the worlds. So, these sons of God
could very well be believers from other
worlds who were presenting themselves or
it could be angels. Um, and then we see
that again, but when you look at the
majority of the texts right here, it
says, "But as many as but as many as
received him, to them he gave power to
become the sons of God." Is it's talking
about angels? No, this is talking about
to as many as received him. Again,
Romans, for as many that as are led by
the spirit of God, they are the sons of
God.
>> They're humans.
>> Yeah, these are just believers.
U for the earnest expectation of the
creature waiteth for the manifestation
of the sons of God,
that ye may be blameless and harmless,
the sons of God, without rebuke. This
these are all referring to people,
believers. Behold, what manner of love
the father has bestowed upon us that we
should be called the sons of God.
Beloved, now we are the sons of God.
Over and over you'll see that the sons
of God are believers, not angels. The
only reference that could refer to the
sons of God being angels is the book of
Job right here. But it doesn't
necessarily it doesn't say 100% that
they are angels. These could very well
be representatives of the other worlds.
Just like Satan came to represent Earth.
It should have been Adam. If Adam would
have never taken a bite of that fruit,
he would have been the representative of
Earth and he would have been the one
that's representing Earth, not Satan.
So, I don't think it's like making huge
leaps and bounds and logic to read this
and understand that Jesus himself said,
"We're going to become like the angels
who don't give into marriage." That's
from Jesus. That's not me. That's not
some like um
denominational view.
>> That's what
>> that's what Jesus said. You have to take
it up with him. Take it up with the very
man himself. Jesus said
>> they do not give in marriage. And then
you said the book of Enoch even said
that they don't give in marriage. Um, so
I I don't see how
non flesh and blood beings who were
created mortal immortal males could have
sex with women and produce offspring.
It's It's not in the Bible. It's not
going to happen.
>> Longtime supporter of Mikey and now and
now his new channel. Thank you so much,
Timothy Thomas. I really appreciate it,
man. You really don't you guys really
have no clue how much your support means
to us. Um,
let's see. I know that my battery is
going to die if I don't get a charger. U
Michelle says, "Hello all
Pharisees kept the Talmud above the
Torah." Yes, that's what I'm thinking,
too. They they added to the law. They
made up all these rules. They got it
from the Talmud.
Oh,
she not she not looking impressed. I
think that's about the cat. Speaking of,
she's right here. She's such a sweetie.
Oh, she makes funny noises.
>> Uh, have you heard about Project Esther?
I know you know about Project 25. I have
not heard about Project Esther. I will
definitely look into that, Michelle.
>> Thank you for I'm gonna type that in
actually right now.
Uh, what is Project Esther?
Project Esther is a policy initiative
launched by the Heritage Foundation in
October 2024.
Ostensibly, what is that? Ostensibly as
a national strategy to combat
anti-semitism. Oh goodness. Oh no.
>> However, critics argue that its true aim
is to dismantle the pro Palestinian
movement in the United States and
suppress dissent against Israel
policies. Wow.
>> No, I actually have not heard about
this, but
I think that this whole there's a lot of
laws that are really pushing us towards
this whole beast system. one of them
being hate speech. You're not allowed to
talk about certain minorities in a bad
way. Um, and part of that also is the
anti-semitism.
These people that we know are not the
Jews of the Bible. They're Zionists.
They're Cabalist. They rule the world
along with Vatican. But, uh, yeah, we
have laws that say you can't say
anything bad about them. Where's the
laws that say you can't say anything bad
about um white Christian males, you
know? We're supposed to be
>> what is it called? We're supposed to be
like white
>> the worst.
>> No, what is it? White privilege. Yeah,
>> we're supposed to be privileged. And yet
>> you can bash my god openly. You can call
me every name in the book and I'm not
protected any kind of way. But somehow
that's privilege. Privilege.
An update about Roger Morno
advises
an Ark of the Covenant found by Wyatt.
>> Are these suggestions for shows?
>> Oh. Oh, hey. Okay. Well, I know Ron
Wyatt's brother personally. I'd love to
have I've actually talked to him many
times about being on the show. We need
to have him on the show because I'm
really interested in in that topic and
knowing more about it.
Uh oh. Where do you think somebody asked
where you think the ark of the covenant
is?
>> Uh I think it's in heaven.
Honestly, isn't that you know Jesus is
our high priest? He's up there doing
what the high priest does.
That's why I'm so like torn about this
because I know Ron Wyatt's brother
personally. I know his nephew
personally.
They say there's no way he would lie
about this. Kent Hovind, who's a very
skeptical person, said that he believes
him 100%.
He knew him personally.
And uh yeah, I don't know, man. I
how it got to heaven, I don't know. I
just feel like if Jesus our high priest
up there doing it, maybe maybe the, you
know, the one that was a earthly ark of
the covenant is still here and maybe the
true ark of the covenants in heaven.
That could be. Um,
but according to Ron Wyatt,
he
put his VHS camera on a tripod, opened
up the Ark of the Covenant, held the Ten
Commandments, an angel was telling him
to do this stuff. and told him to put
the VHS on the ledge in the in the cave
and then at the right time when the mark
of the beast was about to hit that video
would surface. So only time will tell
but that's that is a wild and crazy
claim and I don't have any reason to
believe this guy was lying.
>> So I don't know.
Let's see. What are your what are your
thoughts on miracle healings? I've seen
videos of street preachers praying over
people who have no faith, weren't
seeking healing, and uh doesn't teach
repentance or gospel like party tricks.
H
you know, I wonder if there's any
incences in the Bible where Jesus or an
apostle or something just came up to
somebody who wasn't seeking healing at
all and just like be healed.
Usually Jesus said, "Your faith has made
you well."
>> So I don't know. I mean, I do know that
that Satan can quote unquote heal
people. If if this person on the street
has been living a debaucherous
lifestyle,
that is an open door for Satan to
afflict them. And then some street
preacher who has a false gospel can come
along and say, "Hey man, hey brother,
I'm gonna heal you." And Satan can
remove that affliction and now this
person is going to believe a false
Christ, a false
>> doctrine, a false gospel, false church,
all that stuff. So that very well could
>> That's what I would personally That's
what I would think.
>> Uh we're running out of time, guys. It's
11:00 p.m. I'm trying to make sure we at
least look at some of these.
Mikey, what's your Bible translation
preference? I can talk about that. Did a
video on it.
>> Uh, you know, right now it's King James,
but I'm open to some of these other ones
like the
>> Subtagent and stuff like that. I can't
remember what they're called, the Greek
subtagent or something like that. But I
did a video if you look under our tab or
live tab.
Uh, where is it at? under live,
>> I think.
>> Wow. Is it gone?
>> It might not be there. It might
actually.
>> Oh, here it is.
>> There we go.
>> So, um, this video called these texts
have been removed from the Bible. These
translations are removing text.
I look at a free PDF book. I actually
own the book, too, but it's called In
Thy Word. You can see it on screen right
here. And it shows you where certain
scriptures have been completely twisted
by literally changing one word. Did I
not show this on screen? I did not show
this on screen. Under our live tab, if
you click on this thumbnail that says
these texts have been removed from the
Bible and the thumbnail says these
translations are removing text. Um,
I I look at this book called called In
All Thy Word and it shows you like every
translation and it shows you how
sometimes one word is removed from the
King James and it changes the whole
context. Like imagine if the word not
was removed from a sentence like
or or when it says something like um it
says Israel is a is a withering vine in
the King James and the other versions
say is a flourishing vine is a growing
vine
>> or yeah like I said if you remove the
word not that completely changes the
whole context. So, I haven't, you know,
I'm not like a huge Bible scholar, like
I don't know all these other
translations, but I do know that I think
it's the Greek subtagent or something
like that. The Subtagent Bible is
another one that I think has a a good
translation, but King James, I'm pretty
like
a go-to on the King James.
Um,
I'm trying to see a question.
When are you coming back to Willox,
Arizona? Was I in Willox, Arizona?
>> I don't know.
>> Arizona. Willox. Oh, yeah. Hey, invite
me. That was a good church. That was a
good uh I enjoyed that a lot. I stayed
with a couple there that lived like
totally off-rid. It was awesome. their
whole their whole house was uh powered
by solar and like
generators and stuff. It was very dusty
out there. My clothes were a different a
new shade of gray by the time I left.
But yeah, invite me out to Willox, man.
I'd love to come again.
You Is this a question?
>> No.
>> All right, guys. We're We're wrapping it
up. We're trying to skim through here.
If you guys got any last
Just Curious said, "Hi, fam. What's up?
Good to see you here, sister. You looks
like you got here a little late."
>> Um,
have you seen the cremation of care
video in the Bohemian Grove? Yes. Back
in 2012, I was
>> deep down the rabbit hole watching every
Alex Jones video until 4:00 a.m. And
I've seen it, man. That's where all of
our
governors and presidents and judges and
all that get initiated into the dude you
our world is controlled by Satan. I mean
the Bible literally calls him the god of
this world and it says we do not battle
against flesh and blood but against
principalities against the rulers of the
darkness of this world. like Satan is
running ruling through people and um all
these people man they believe in Moolok
and they go out there to Bohemian Grove
and do these ritual sacrifices and
things. What this one
>> the one above it I was gonna
>> How many children do you have and ages?
I have one daughter who's 14 years old
from a previous marriage and she's
awesome and had a and actually had a
daughter that passed away as well who
was special needs and she was 15 when
she passed and she'd probably be about
going on 19 now.
Yeah. I think there's a lot about people
that people don't know. You know, I like
Doug Bachelor. I watch him a lot and uh
he had a child that passed away and
you'd like never know some of these
things about people.
Me and Aubrey do not have children. We
wish to keep it that way. We don't want
to bring a child into this crazy world.
Woe unto them who give suck in the last
days. No offense to anybody who's
pregnant or has a little kid, but man,
this world is crazy. I don't I think
there's enough children in the world
that we need to take care of and to
teach the truth right now. And God made
me a
a woman of his cause, not actually a
a woman who wants to be a mother. So
>> yeah, you never had that desire.
>> Nope.
Uh
do you think Ron why is a fraud? I don't
I honestly don't you know the the the
Ark of the Covenant thing is like the
hardest thing to believe out of
everything that I've ever heard from
him. But I have no reason to believe
that he uh
he's lying. Someone asked, "Did Ellen
White start the SDA?" No, she didn't. It
was a Baptist minister
named Mar um William Miller
who suddenly in an instant understood a
prophecy in the Bible in Daniel
um about what that meant about the
cleansing of the temple coming and and
they used to think it meant that Jesus
was coming to earth to cleanse the earth
but really it meant that Jesus was going
to become our high priest in the
heavenly sanctuary and start a judgment.
And we know that that's true that we're
going through a judgment period right
now that you know Christ isn't going to
return without
looking at everyone's case and
everyone's situation. And you look at
the book of Genesis before God brought
judgment, before he brought the flood,
it says he came down and he investigated
the situation. and he looked. Every time
God brought judgment, it always says
that he heard the cries of the people
and he went down and looked. He doesn't
make knee-jerk reactions and say, "I'm
sick of this. I'm destroying them all."
He always goes down, investigates. And
um one of the verses that I use about
intercessory prayer,
I always forget which book it's in. It's
in my slides, but
um God was going to bring judgment upon
Jerusalem. I think
>> and it and it it said he looked to see
if anyone was standing in the gap and
found none.
>> Not even one person was praying for that
city. And so he had to bring judgment
because as much as God is merciful and
gracious, he's also justice. And you
know, if one person would have been
praying for that city, it could have
spared the whole city. You know Jonah
was one person and he went into the city
begrudgingly and gave a message and
converted the whole city. Moses
interceded for the Israelites and one
man Moses changed the whole changed
God's mind completely. Says that God
repented of this wicked thing he thought
to do of destroying the Israelites. Even
though they were worshiping a golden
calf, he had every right to do so but
the prayers of one man. So anyway, I got
off track. Um, William Miller
had this understanding of a prophecy in
Daniel about Jesus entering into the
most holy place.
And um, Ellen White was like 14 years
old at the time. He was a Baptist. There
was no such thing as a Seventh Day
Adventist church at the time. And Ellen
White was a a teenager, young teenager.
And many people of different faiths at
that time were all coming to these new
truths. And they were all like, "Wait a
minute. All these churches are teaching
false doctrine. We need to start a
movement."
And they started going out and teaching
people to come back to the Bible and
away from tradition. And they didn't
really have a name for the movement. And
so they had to kind of form a
denomination just out of necessity.
How do you tell people you're witnessing
to
what church you're a part of or where to
go and all that stuff? So, that's where
the denomination of the Adventist church
came in. But Adventism is really a
movement about bringing people back to
the truth of the Bible away from
tradition.
Um,
looks like we're reaching the end of
the questions here.
And man, I see a lot of new faces in
here, too. It's cool.
And
what is this? Something about animation.
>> This says, "Uh, hey guys. I used to work
in the animation industry prior to
becoming SDA. What are your thoughts on
using animation to spread the gospel? Is
it wrong to use allegory or fiction? Not
at all. I mean, Jesus literally told
stories every sermon. Every sermon was a
story.
>> Yeah. You just don't have to bring in
the dark mythological or pedophile type
elements that animation usually has in
it.
>> Yeah. There's so many people that act
like, well, if we can't use magic and we
can't use this and that, then how can we
even make a story? Man, have you ever
watched a Peanuts episode with Snoopy?
Have you ever watched like Garfield? I
mean, there's so many shows and cartoons
and stuff that don't involve sorcery and
violence and wicked things. And uh I
love watching Bible cartoons. And I
would love to see more animation.
>> Oh, wait a minute. Somebody said, "I'm
sorry, Mikey, for the loss of your
daughters. Really sorry. Thank you."
That was four years ago. And then my mom
was just months ago. Uh
just like King David. Rejoice, brother.
You'll see her again. Amen. I will. What
happened with LED?
So when my mom got sick, she had a
stroke. I'm an only child. My dad was
taking care of her and working and stuff
like that mean
>> what does LED studios? Yeah.
>> Light exposing darkness. Um, the last
year that I was working at Little Light
was my seventh year there. I just felt
this strong burden like I need to be
home more so I can help my dad. I need
to be more available to help my dad with
my mom and stuff. And Aubrey had started
working there too. And she was working
there for like six months. And I was
feeling like I need to be home more. How
am I going to do that? Maybe I need to
start my own ministry. How do I even do
that? I have no idea how to how to step
away from a steady paycheck and to step
out in faith to start a ministry. I had
no idea what that looked like. I had no
savings or anything. I just I didn't
know what to do. And Aubrey started
having the same conviction on her like
that God was calling her into ministry.
And we had just got married and we're
like,
"Okay, we both feel like we need to be
home more. We need to we have things
that we want to talk about that are
maybe too controversial for other
platforms. One of them was holidays.
Little didn't want to talk about the
holidays. I wanted to talk about the
truth about the shape of the earth. I
knew that was never going to be a topic
we talked about.
And I knew there was going to be more. I
knew there was going to be more
controversial things that I feel very
led to talk about. And I didn't know if
that was always going to be possible
uh unless we had our own ministry. And
so
Aubrey did have some savings and I was
like, you know what, let's just take a
leap of faith. Worst case scenario, a
couple months goes by and it doesn't
work out, I'll just go back to work. You
know, I mean, and you know, even Scotty
from Little Light said, "Man, six months
goes by and it's not working out. Just
come on back, man." So, they were very
supportive of our decision. especially
because it, you know, was me helping
take care of my mom and stuff like that.
And from month one, God was providing
um we were able to make our mortgage
just from donors in the first month. And
then, and I mean a month's mortgage, not
like pay the mortgage off or anything,
but the next month, we were able to make
mortgage and bills. And then the next
month, mortgage bills and groceries. And
then it was like we started praying God
we we feel that you are calling us to do
this. We are praying that you will match
what we used to make because we were
used to living on that and um it doesn't
happen monthto month but at the end of
the year is when a lot of people give
you know a lot of more wealthier people
give because they it's a tax thing. I
don't know anything about being wealthy
and having to give away money for tax
purposes, but it happens. And so, um,
this ministry
has survived so far because a lot of,
uh, donations come at the end of the
year.
>> We get enough each month to survive.
And, and that's just the honest truth of
it. That's the candid truth is that we
we do make enough to survive. And we are
so thankful for those of you who are
giving. Some of you are giving every
month and it's amazing and we can't do
it without you and we can't thank you
enough. And for those of you who give
that one time at the end of the year,
you are awesome, too. And we cannot
thank you enough. And it's because of
you that we can even do this. And we've
been doing it for a year and I see many
more years to come.
Uh,
hey,
Advent age is up in here. What's up,
Jeremy and Megan? Good to see you guys,
man.
You should check out Advent Age. They
got a lot of good stuff going on. They
they do camp meetings often where they
have multiple speakers. Really good
speakers come out and people camp out
for the weekend.
Uh,
okay. There are a lot of comments, but
it looks like not a lot of questions.
Let's see. It looks like y'all are doing
well. Praise God. Almost 10k subs.
Almost 9,100.
>> God is good. We got that in about a
year. Thanks, Mike and Aubrey. Stay
strong. Stay safe. Stay alert.
I reached the end.
Thank you guys so much for being here. I
hope it was edifying. I hope it was
interesting. I hope we answered some
good questions from you guys.
And um if you guys want to support this
ministry, you can do so by going to
candidtruth.org.
We got many different ways to give. Cash
App, Vinmo, Zel, and PayPal. Just to
make sure you guys know, we do have
PayPal. Somebody thought we didn't have
PayPal. And we also have some cool
t-shirts with Bible verses and cool
slogans like, "Be cool, use your brain."
That's what we're all about here at Can
of Truth is making it cool again to use
your brain. And that comes with Bible
study and looking at
uh current events through the lens of
the Bible and all that stuff. But we
love you guys. We thank you guys. We
cannot do this without you. Did you have
any final thoughts?
>> Nope. Thanks for tuning in.
>> Yeah. Thanks for being here, guys. And
we'll see you very soon. We got Minnow
tomorrow 8:00 p.m. Minnow coming with
some hard-hitting truth about the N. The
>> actually he's exposing all of it.
exposing it all. Everything. Nothing
left.
>> Last time, last time was just an
introduction to it and how it gets
started, but it is going to be
everything.
>> Yep. And guys, sorry about the delay.
It's been like eight days since we went
live. We were sick. We've been
traveling. We're working on stuff. We
got a video that's being edited right
now to put out. It's like a produced
video about culture. You guys are going
to want to see that because a lot of
people accept sinful
things under the guise of culture. And
it's a pretty controversial topic
because when you start talking about
people's culture, it's like you're
stepping on their toes. But we love you
guys. We thank you guys. We cannot do
this without you. And we cannot thank
you guys enough for all your love and
support. And we will see you tomorrow on
Can of Truth.